The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Time for some more geometry,
and, in particular,
some more fractional
cascading, which
is a cool topic we
saw last lecture.
And then we're going to do
a different kind of data
structure called
kinetic data structures,
where you have moving data.
And that will actually
be most of the lecture.
But last time, we saw this
nice general black box
transformation,
fractional cascading,
and we didn't really see a
lot of applications of it.
We saw a simple example in
orthogonal range searching.
But I want to show you
today a much cooler
one in the original
fractional cascading papers.
So remember, in
general, what it lets
you do is search for
a common element x,
find its predecessor and
successor in k sorted lists,
in order log n plus
k time, instead
of the obvious k
times log n, where
n is the length of each list.
And the general version
that we talked about
is, if you're
navigating a graph,
and at each node of the graph,
you have one of these lists,
then you can instantly know
where x fits in that list
in constant time per thing, as
long as you spend log n time
to get started, provided your
graph has bounded degree.
That was necessary to do
all the fractional cascading
stuff of copying half
into the next level up.
So we're going to
use this result
to get a lag factor improvement
in our old friend orthogonal
range searching.
So let's do orthogonal
So last time, we
saw how to do two
dimensional orthogonal range
searching in log n per query.
That was using fractional
cascading, or, really,
half of fractional
cascading, which
was just a cross-linking idea.
This time we're going to do
3D orthogonal range searching
in log n time.
Our space is going to go
up by a couple log factors.
But this is pretty cool.
In general, for d
dimensions, this
gives us log to the d minus
two, whereas last class, we saw
how to do log the d minus 1.
Now, this is static only.
You could probably
do poly-log update.
But let's not worry
about updates.
We're just trying to do static.
So 3D orthogonal range search
using fractional cascading--
this is kind of a tour de force.
There's a really
cool result. It's
in the "Applications of
Fractional Cascading"
paper by Chazelle and Guibas.
And it proceeds in
four easy steps.
Each of the steps are easy,
but it's kind of amazing
where we get to.
We're going to start out with
a two dimensional restricted
orthogonal range query.
We'll see why at the very end.
But this is actually
from another paper
of Chazelle in the same year.
OK, in general,
remember, in 3-D,
we're trying to do
querying with a rectangle--
a1, b1, a2, b2, a3, b3.
We want to know all the
points in that rectangle.
So I'm going to start out with
a very restricted form, which
is only two dimensional,
for whatever reason.
And we'll see why later.
y-coordinate and
z-coordinate, skipping x--
and the left end
point doesn't exist.
So you go all the way up to
b2, and you go all the way up
to b3.
This is a quarter plane
in two dimensions.
I want to know all
the points in there.
It's the same as saying
all the points that
are dominated by this point.
Both y- and z-coordinates
are dominated
by that yz coordinate.
This is b2, b3.
So we can solve this
in log n time plus k.
But I want to be a little bit
more precise about what that
log in is, and say that
this costs whatever it costs
to search for b3, the
z-coordinate, in a z list--
in a list of
z-coordinates of points--
plus order k.
I write it this
way because if we
have many searches among lists,
then we can speed things up.
So I don't want to just
think of it as log n.
I want to think of it as one
of these fractional cascading
operations.
So this is the time bound I
want to get for finding the k
points in this search range.
Now, here's the fun part.
We're going to transform this
into a kind of stabbing ray
problem, like we saw last class,
and in the retroactive stuff,
and so on.
So let's suppose I
have some points.
I'm just going to draw
an arbitrary arrangement.
Hopefully, it's
reasonably interesting.
Those are the points I
want to be able to query.
And if I'm given, say,
a query like this one,
I want to know all
the points in here.
So what I'm going to do is
draw a leftward horizontal ray
from the query point.
And I'm going to draw--
maybe use a color--
upward vertical rays
from each of the points.
OK.
And where there's
crossings, those
correspond to points that are
in the query quarter plane.
OK, so same problem--
but now, thinking about rays.
So here's a cool thing you
can do with this approach.
So we want to preprocess these
vertical rays so that, then, we
can stab with a horizontal ray.
And it's actually
easier to think of it
as coming from the
left, because that's
kind of a consistent
x-coordinate,
and walking to the right.
I'd like to find
this intersection,
then find this one,
then find this one.
Eventually, I get to the
desired y-coordinate.
This is the y direction,
and this is z direction.
Then I stop.
So if I could get started
over here in log n time,
and then do a walk in constant
time per intersection,
I'd be golden.
That is possible.
And the way that
Chazelle did this--
I'm going to erase
the query ray--
is to decompose the plane
in a pretty simple way.
We're going to draw a horizontal
segment from each point.
We're going to extend
it to the right
until it hits something,
extend it to the left.
In this case, it
goes off to infinity.
Here, I extend this guy.
I extend this guy.
And extend this one out here.
I'm going to add one
more point over here--
a little more exciting.
So this stops there.
This goes to there.
AUDIENCE: One
more-- to the right.
ERIK DEMAINE: One
more up here-- thanks.
OK.
So this is kind of decomposition
into slabs or bricks
or something.
It looks good.
And so the idea is, over
here, there's, at most, n
different rays that make
it all the way to the left.
Do a search.
That's your z search.
So that's this search
for b3 in the z list.
So remember, our goal
is to get to here.
So we search for that
z-coordinate over here.
We say, OK, it falls here.
Then I enter this face.
I'd like to then
navigate to this face,
say, OK, that's where I am now.
By crossing this edge, I know
that this point is actually
in my answer.
And then I cross this edge,
so I know that this point
is in my answer.
Then I cross this ray,
so I know that this point
is in my answer.
Then I say, OK, I reached
my desired y-coordinate.
Stop.
So if I can do each of these
traversals in constant time,
I'd be all set.
So I do one search at
the beginning, then
constant time per query.
We know how to
solve this problem.
We can do it with range trees
and log n time preparation.
But this is a particular
way to solve it
that will work with
fractional cascading
when we do many of them.
OK.
Cool.
Can I do this in constant time?
Maybe not, because it's
this sort of scenario.
If I draw a whole bunch
of points like this,
they'll each have a segment.
And in general, this face
will have large degree.
And so I need to sort of
find my z-coordinate again,
somewhere in here.
It turns out, with, essentially,
fractional cascading again,
you can avoid that.
If you have many segments
here, just extend half of them.
So maybe I'll extend this
one over and this one over.
It looks like
fractional cascading.
I'm taking half of
the elements here,
inserting them into the
previous list, which
is the left side of the face.
If this now has too many, well,
half of them get promoted.
But it decreases exponentially.
And so the total amount of
extra edges I'm adding here
is only linear.
So linear space--
I'm not going to prove
this formally here,
but it's the same idea
as fractional cascading.
We just need it as
a tool to get to 3D.
You can extend these
things, and then every face
will have bounded degree.
And so you can just look at
every single rightward edge
in constant time,
and figure out which
one has your z-coordinate.
Follow that edge.
And so every time
you're crossing a ray
and getting an output, you
can pay only constant time
to get it.
Pretty cool.
That's the first step.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So when you say
that a particular face has
too many crossings, what
do you define too many?
ERIK DEMAINE: More
than a constant.
In general, you just look
at the right side of a face,
and just take half
of those things
and propagate it to the left.
Just do that right
to left in one pass.
I think you might also need
to do it left to right,
if you want to have
bounded leftward degree.
But I'm not sure
that really matters.
I think you just do
one pass right to left,
and half the guys
keep getting promoted.
And it's the same thing, where
you're promoting from the LI
primes, not from the LI.
So it's everybody who
came from the right plus
whatever you originally had.
Half of them get
promoted to the left,
but because it's geometrically
decreasing, all is OK.
This is earlier than
fractional cascading,
but I would guess it's what
motivated them to then do
general fractional cascading.
Other questions?
I know this is a
little bit vague.
But the more exciting stuff,
to me, is the next three steps.
So let's move on to those. .
So this is a tool for doing
two dimensional quarter
plane searching.
The next thing we're going to
do is make it three dimensional.
This is actually something
we already know how to do.
And we're going to do it
in exactly the same way we
knew how to before.
Suppose you have a
three dimensional query,
and two of the intervals
start at minus infinity,
but the new x-coordinate
is a regular interval.
You can specify both endpoints.
I want to do this in
log n searches plus k.
k is the size of the output.
How do I do this using one?
Two words-- range tree.
Yep.
Easy.
Just do 1D range tree on x.
And then each node stores
that data structure--
one-- on points in the subtree.
And so just like before,
you get log n subtrees
that represent your x interval.
You look at the
root of each one,
and it stores a
one data structure.
You query each of
them for b2 and b3
for that interval among
the y- and z-coordinates.
And each of them costs
a search plus order k.
The k's sum up to order k.
So we end up doing
log n searches
of that type plus k time.
And we can now solve
this kind of 3D query.
This is really easy.
This is what we did last class.
The cool thing, of course, is
that, by doing log n searches,
it's always searching
for the same thing-- b3--
in various c lists.
We know by fractional cascading
this is actually log n time.
We're doing log n
searches in k lists--
and slightly different
k here, sorry.
It's actually log n lists.
But we know from this
bound, we're going
to get order log n plus k.
But I don't want to do
fractional cascading yet,
because we're not done.
This is a sort of three
dimensional orthogonal range
query.
But I want to put
a2 here and a3 here.
We're going to do
that step by step.
First step is a2.
We're going to do it in
exactly the same way, twice.
Again, I want to do it
in log n searches plus k.
It's the same time bound
I want to put into a2.
The cost will be a
log n factor in space.
And it's a cool transformation.
It's a general transformation.
Whenever you have a data
structure has a minus infinity,
you can turn it into a
lower bound, magically--
almost the same
way as we did here,
except we're not going to
lose a log factor in time--
only in space.
So I'm going to say it's
kind of like a range
tree on the y-coordinate.
y-coordinate
is the one that
we want to extend.
And you may remember there was
this brief question last time.
In a 1D range tree, what
key does a node store?
It just has to store
something that's
in between what's
in the left subtree
and what's in the right subtree.
So I proposed you could
store max of left subtree.
And that's enough
to do a search.
Then you know whether you
should go in the left subtree
or the right subtree.
Just compare with that key.
So same as before-- we're
going to store that key.
Except now, I'm
making it explicit,
because we really need
to know what that key is.
A node v will also
store two of these.
So it's going to store the two
data structure on the points
in the right subtree--
not the entire subtree,
just the right subtree.
And it's going to store a
y-inverted two structure
on points in the left subtree.
So this is the new part.
And what does y-inverted mean?
It means that you can
search for boxes like this.
So regularly, a two structure
is sort of left-centered,
and the left end
point is undefined,
and it goes up to b3.
Now, I want something
that's right-centered.
It goes up to infinity
on the right side.
But you can start
at an arbitrary a2.
How do I make such a
data structure do exactly
the same thing, but with
this inverted, which means,
do exactly this, but
with this inverted?
Easy to do-- just twice
as many data structures.
So you can think of that
as one prime and two prime.
I'll call this two
prime, explicitly.
OK, now, the big question
is, why is this enough?
So let's do that.
How do I do a query in
data structure three?
The basic idea is simple.
We're going to
walk down the tree.
Now, before we
walk down the tree,
and the interval is represented
by log n different subtrees--
we can't afford that anymore.
We can really only afford
a constant number of calls
to this data structure,
if we're not going
to get an extra log blowup.
So I don't want to walk and
then fork and then visit
all these subtrees.
I could do that.
But it turns out,
with this structure,
I can be a little
bit more efficient.
Because, essentially, I want
to do an interval like this.
The queries I'm
allowed is, I can
do a query that's
infinite to the left,
and I can do a query that's
infinite to the right.
So the intersection of
those would be what I want.
I can't really
compute intersection.
So it take too much
time to list those.
But if, somehow, I could
get this left endpoint
in another way, using
the tree, then I
can do a leftward
infinity query.
So that's what
we're going to do.
And once I say
walk down the tree,
it's pretty clear
what you have to do.
When you visit a node, if the
key of the node is less than--
what are you searching
for-- a2, b2--
so a2 is less than b2.
And if the key of the
node is to the left,
that means that the stuff we're
interested to is to the right.
So walk right.
If the key of the node is
greater than the interval,
then walk left.
That's sort of the easy case.
And then the interesting
case is this fork.
Before, we had to do a
lot of work at the fork.
Now, I claim we only need to
do constant work at the fork.
So if the key falls
between a2 and b2,
so our interval is stabbed
by the key of the node,
then I want to query
the two data structure--
two is the right number-- yeah--
and I want to query the
two prime data structure.
So I'm going to do two
calls to data structure two.
And so I only get a
constant factor blowup.
And what could I
possibly search for?
Well, two-- I'm able to do--
what is it-- a1, b1,
minus infinity b2,
and minus infinity b3.
We're not fixing the
z-coordinate yet.
And with two prime, I can do
the left endpoint bounded.
Once I've set things up,
this is, like, the only thing
you could possibly do.
But I claim it's actually
the right answer.
OK, what does this mean?
Two prime is-- we're doing
rightward infinity searches
in the left subtree.
So here's v. Here is
the left subtree of v,
and the right subtree of v.
So this is a bunch of points
down here, a bunch
of points down here.
We know that the interval
looks something like this.
It straddles this node.
That's what this means.
And so what we'd really like
is this stuff plus this stuff.
That looks good.
Because this goes to
infinity on the right.
That's the two prime search.
And this goes to
infinity on the left.
That's the two search.
As long as you restrict
to this subtree, which
is what we've always been
doing, and, in particular,
here, too, it's
only on the points
that are in the right subtree.
Two prime is only on the
points in the left subtree.
And so that's it.
We're golden.
Actually, we only need to do
a rightward infinity search,
and a leftward infinity search.
So that is data structure three.
And it's really easy.
Once you have the ability
to do a 3D search--
even if this one was
minus infinity b1--
if we just could do--
would you call that-- octants--
octant search in 3D,
then we could just
sit there and apply
this transformation,
and turn each one of them into
double-sided, with a log n
penalty each time in space,
but no extra query time.
We do a single log n
traversal of this tree.
So this part costs log n.
And then we reduce to
the previous problem--
it's constant number of calls.
So I could have written
minus infinity here.
But I pay an extra
log factor in space.
So this one we get for
free, because we're
using range trees.
We do one transformation.
We get this one.
And now we're basically
done, because we just do this
again on the
z-coordinate, and we
get a1, b1, a2, b2,
a3, b3, as desired.
For our queries, just
ditto on z, and using three
in place of two.
So we want to add in this a3.
We build a three data structure.
We build three prime
data structures
in exactly the same way.
Three primes are on the left.
Threes are on the right.
Every node in this
range tree on z.
And we do a log n
search at the beginning.
Then we do a constant of calls
to the data structure three.
Data structure three
does a log n search
at the beginning--
constant number
of calls to data structure two.
Data structure two does our
usual range tree thing--
identifies log n different
calls to data structure one.
Data structure one is
a search and a list,
plus every time I walk to the
right and spend constant time,
that is an element of my output.
How much time has
this taken total?
Normally, there's log n
of these, plus order of k.
Normally, that would be
log squared n plus k.
But with fractional cascading--
we have to check this is valid
within fractional cascading.
We've got a graph of
data structures here,
but each node has
only constant degree.
You can come from your parent.
You can go to your left child.
You can go to your right child.
And you can go to previous
dimension data structure,
or the inverted version of it.
So the degree five--
if you count in and out degree.
And so fractional
cascading applies.
We're always searching
for the same thing--
not quite, actually-- a
little bit of a cheat.
Because of this
inversion thing, we'll
sometimes be searching
for b3 in the z list,
but we'll also sometimes be
searching for a3 in the z list.
But hey-- just a factor of two.
So we have two fractional
cascading data structures--
one for searching for b3,
one for searching for a3.
It's the inverted
versions of one,
and the uninverted
versions of one--
z-inverted.
But that's fine.
And in the end, we get log n to
do the first search, and then
plus the number of searches.
Number of searches is
log n plus k, where
k is the size of the output.
So total time is log n plus k.
This is pretty amazing.
We can do 3D orthogonal range
queries, still in log n.
And if you go to higher
dimensions, the best we know,
basically, is to
use range trees.
And so you get, in general, log
to the d minus two n plus k.
So last class, we could do one.
Now, we improved it by one more.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a quick question.
[INAUDIBLE] question.
So we do three, and
then we do four.
And it's not hard to imagine
that same [INAUDIBLE], when
you might try to do the same
argument for step three, step
four, step five.
ERIK DEMAINE: Why can't we keep
doing this for all dimensions?
So what three is,
and also four, is
using the same
transformation, which
is, if I have a minus
infinity something interval,
I can transform it into
an a2, b2 interval.
So I can make a one-sided
interval into two-sided.
The trouble is actually
getting the one-sided interval.
So we started, in one
and two, just getting up
to three dimensions.
And that's where
things are hard.
So fine, in two
dimensions, we can
do all sorts of fancy tricks.
We saw one way to
do it last time.
This is a particularly
cute way to do it
that lets you
fractionally cascade.
We could add a dimension.
To add a dimension, we
just use range trees.
This is kind of pathetic.
Every time we do this, we're
going to pay a log n factor.
So we could afford to do
it once and get to 3D.
We paid a log n
factor here, but we
were lucky fractional
cascading will remove
one log factor, but only one.
If we had to go to
four dimensions,
we'd have to use another
level of range trees.
And then we'd get a
log squared searches.
And then we have to pay
unit cost for every search.
So we'll get log squared
for four dimensions.
So it's just getting
up to the right number
of dimensions that's hard.
What you're seeing here is
that one-sided intervals
are just the same as
two-sided intervals,
if you don't mind extra space.
The space here is, I think,
log cubed n log cubed n.
Data structure one is linear
space, but every other level,
we lost a log factor.
So one of those was to get up
a dimension by range trees.
The other two were to convert
the one-sided intervals
into two-sided intervals.
And that generalizes.
You could do that as
many times as you want.
The hard part is just getting
the right number of intervals
in the first place.
And that's where we
pay log per dimension.
So kind of annoying you can't do
log n for any dimension, but--
pretty sure that's impossible.
There are models under
which it's impossible,
but we're not going
to get into that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when our
query is log n plus k,
k is actually the
number of points
that are coming back, because--
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Good question.
Here, k has to be--
this is for what we
call range reporting,
where you really want to
list everybody in there.
And if we wanted to do range
counting queries, which just
give me the number of
elements that match,
I don't think this will work.
In particular, our seed
data structure up here
had to pay for everything.
It doesn't know how
many times it's going
to have to walk to the right.
It's got to actually do it.
So range counting-- not so much.
Our previous data
structures could do range
counting, without the
plus k, just paying log
to the d minus one.
But this is just
for range reporting.
Good question.
I don't think anyone knows how
to do range counting faster.
AUDIENCE: And the
reason we're only
hitting points we know about
is because the one data
structure is on the bottom,
so we never actually--
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
So you need to check, why
is it only order k, where
k is the actual output size?
Because by the time we get
down to the one data structural
level, we're guaranteed
that x already matches.
It's already in our interval
a1, b1 by the range tree.
And we're guaranteed that
these two open intervals--
the minus infinity
actually is a2 here,
and it actually is a3
here, or, actually,
something bigger than it.
So we're guaranteed whatever
this thing outputs is a result.
And we're never doing
overlapping intervals.
So we never double charge.
Yeah.
You do need to check that.
There's a lot of pointers to
follow here, but it works.
All right.
You look convinced.
Let's move on to
kinetic data structures.
The idea with kinetic
data structures
is, you have moving data.
Deal with it.
So normally, we're
thinking of data that--
at best, it's
dynamic data, meaning
we can delete something
and then reinsert it.
But what if everything
is constantly changing?
So normally, OK, I've got some
points in my data structure.
But now, what if they
also have velocities?
And maybe some guy's just
sitting there stationary,
but some of them are
moving relative to it.
And my operations-- this is
kind of like time travel,
but now we're going
to time travel
into the future, which
we do all the time.
But we'd like to do it
really quickly, and say, OK,
advanced time by five units.
And now, in that frame, do
an orthogonal range query
or something.
Do some kind of query.
We're always going to be
doing queries in the present.
So this is not
fancy time travel.
This is regular,
forward time travel.
We just want to quickly say,
jump forward 10 time units,
do some queries, jump forward
some other time units.
There's actually another
operation, which is, ah,
this point is no longer
moving in that direction.
Now, it's moving
in this direction.
So the operations are,
advance to time t--
so this is like setting
now equal to t--
and change a point x to have
some new f of t trajectory.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
supposed to be arbitrary.
ERIK DEMAINE: Well, arbitrary
trajectory is not-- not quite.
I'm going to restrict what
those trajectories are.
But that is the
remaining question.
What kind of f of
t's do we allow?
I'm drawing the picture in
d dimensions, let's say.
And most of the work in
kinetic structures in 2D--
a little bit in 3D--
but I'm going to focus
today mostly on 1D.
Because it's easy
to analyze, clean.
There's a lot of
open questions in 2D.
So we can also think of these--
there's points on a line.
They have velocities,
accelerations, who knows what.
That would be--
OK, let's say-- models
of trajectories.
The simplest one that
would be affine--
f of t equals a plus bt.
a and b here would be
points. a and d dimensions
are just values
in one dimension.
So the motivation is, maybe,
you have cell phones or cars
or something.
You have some current
estimates on which way
they're going and at what speed.
Then this would be
the simple model.
And if either those
two things change,
you have to do a
change operation.
So you pay for that every time
they change their trajectory.
But otherwise, it's going
to be super efficient,
because advance is
going to be super fast.
That's the plan.
But maybe it's not just
position and speed.
Maybe also have
acceleration and stuff.
And then the extension
of that would
be bounded degree
algebraic, which
is, you have some polynomial
of bounded degree--
sorry, that should be c--
but bounded.
And the reason we
care about bounded
is really the following.
There's an even
more general model
which we call pseudo algebraic.
So we would like to bound the
cost of this advance operation.
What we'd like is that when we
advance time a large amount,
stuff doesn't change
crazy number of times.
And pseudo algebraic says
that if you look at anything
you care about-- we call this
a certificate of interest.
We'll be talking a lot
about certificates today.
Certificate is
something like, is
this point left of that point.
It's a Boolean question
about the moving points.
It's either true or false.
And what I'd like is that--
I have some point.
It has some crazy trajectory.
I have another point.
I don't want, is this
point left of this point,
to change an unbounded
number of times.
I'd like it to be constant,
as long as no change
operations are called.
So for a single
trajectory, I'd like
these to flip a constant
number of times.
Now, if you're algebraic
with bounded degree,
then that will be the case.
But more generally,
as long as you sort of
switch between left and right
bounded number of times,
then that particular
certificate will only change
unbounded number of times.
But in general, anything
where all the certificates
I care about change a
constant number of times
is just as good as algebraic.
This is really why we like this.
I think I've talked enough
about trajectory models.
So it's not totally generic.
But it covers a lot of
things you might care about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
certificate of interest?
ERIK DEMAINE:
Certificate of interest
is just a Boolean function
on a constant number of data
points over time-- a constant
number of trajectories,
I should say.
I'll probably actually
define certificate right now.
AUDIENCE: Good.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Certificates-- I'm going
to define them more
as a tool that we
use to build data structures,
but they're really
the same thing that I mean here.
So pretty much all
kinetic data structures
follow this unified approach.
Kinetic data structures are
actually a pretty new thing,
introduced in 1999.
So as data structures
go, that's new.
And over the last however
many years that is--
13-- there's been a bunch
of kinetic data structures.
So what we're going to do
is store the data structure
that is accurate now.
So this will make queries
about the present really easy.
It just is .
You look at the data
structure, you do a query.
And so the hard part
becomes, how do I do advance?
How do I advance time and make
the new data structure, which
is correct, about the new now?
The way we do that
is with certificates.
So what I'm going to do is
additionally store, basically,
a proof that this data
structure is valid.
We can say conditions
which are currently true--
and as long as they remain
true, the data structure
remains valid.
So these conditions
are true now, and--
sorry-- under which
data structure
is accurate or correct.
And those conditions
are true now.
OK, so for example--
well, we'll get to
examples in a moment.
We'll just keep abstract
for a little bit longer.
Each of these certificates, you
can figure out a failure time.
So you have some
certificate, like, this point
is to the left of that point.
And you just look ahead in time.
If you have some constant
defined trajectories,
you just see, when
is the time when they
will be aligned vertically?
After that time, they're going
to switch who is left of whom.
So just compute
that failure time.
I'm going to assume--
that's another assumption
about the trajectory model--
that this takes constant
time for trajectory.
I do that for every certificate,
and then put those failure
times into a priority queue.
Do you want to
ask your question?
AUDIENCE: So is it required
that a certificate needs to be--
like, that we've checked
that a certificate is true.
It just needs to be
bounded by order one, or--
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So I'm assuming checking
a certificate takes
constant time, whether
it currently holds,
and computing the failure
time takes constant time.
Yeah.
I mean, you could assume it,
or maybe you pay a little more.
I mean, this is how we're going
to build the data structure.
So whatever it
costs, it will cost.
But I think everything
we'll talk about
and pretty much every
certificate out there
is sort of a
constant size thing.
Some of them are bigger.
But we'll get to
the costs involved.
Maybe we won't worry
about time too much.
So priority queue is going
to take log n time, where
n is the number of certificates
in the data structure, to find,
when is the next failure?
So if I want to do an
advance, basically, I'm
going to do discrete
event simulation.
I find the next event
when something changes,
i.e. a certificate fails.
I'm going to fix that event--
fix that certificate-- make the
data structure correct again.
Then advance to
the next failure.
Repeat.
As long as there aren't too
many certificates to mess me up,
this advance will be fast.
So yeah.
So here's how we're going
to implement advance.
Basically in all
kinetic data structures,
we just say, while
t is greater than
or equal to the next failure
of the priority queue,
we advance to that
moment in time,
when something
interesting happens.
We do an event.
I'll write it this way.
And then we set now to t.
And this event thing has to
somehow fix the data structure
and fix the certificates.
So that is the challenge, is,
how do you deal with an event
when one of your
certificates breaks?
So if you have a data structure,
and you want to make it,
kinetic you just first
write down some certificates
under which it's
guaranteed to be valid,
and then see how to fix
them as things happen.
Then there's the analysis
issue, which we will get to.
Let's start with an example
before we get to analyzing,
so this becomes a
little more concrete.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are the change
operations sort of online,
or do you have the
sequence of changes
that you're going to [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: All of these
operations are online.
So at any moment, someone says
advance, someone says change,
or someone says query.
And query is respect to now.
So we have no idea which
of these are coming,
in what order, whatever.
I don't think anyone's
studied the case where
you know up front all the
things that are going to happen.
Though there are, presumably,
applications for that.
I mean, time can just be a
euphemism for a dimension,
or whatever.
But a lot of the
kinetic people really
want to be tracking points and
maintaining what's happening.
So let's do a 1D problem--
a simple one-- sort of
the most basic problem,
which is a predecessor problem.
Insert, delete.
We won't worry too much
about insert and delete here.
It's hard enough, because the
points are moving around--
and predecessor and successor.
So I want to know, on the
line, I have some points.
They're moving.
Now, query is, at the current
time, who's to the left
and who's to the
right of this query?
OK.
How do we maintain this?
This is a problem we'll be
studying a lot in this class.
But the basic structure for
solving predecessor, insert,
delete, predecessor, is--
AUDIENCE: Binary search tree.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Binary search tree--
balanced binary search tree.
OK, so let's use a log n
high AVL trees-- whatever.
So what do we need
for certificates?
I was going to use
this as an example,
but it's actually
a little tricky
to think about what
the certificates are.
Because the binary
search tree property
is x plus or equal to x
greater or equal to x.
That's kind of a
lot of certificates.
If I want to compare x to
every single guy in here
and compare x to every single
guy in here, that would be a,
I think, quadratic number
of certificates, in general.
Almost everyone has a relation.
I'd prefer to get away
with fewer certificates.
Because then, less
certificates will fail.
So cute idea--
I really only need to compare x
with this one and this one. --
the max in the subtree and
the min in the subtree.
In general, if I look at
the data in sorted order,
it has to stay
sorted order, where
it's not going to be sorted.
But this is an
inorder traversal.
Inorder traversal
is something we
can understand without
knowing what the data is.
Because remember, data
is constantly changing.
We can't really
use the keys here.
But we can use the
abstract shape of the tree
and do an inorder
traversal, and say, look,
as long as x i is less than
or equal to x i plus one
in the inorder
traversal for all i,
then this is a valid
binary search tree.
If an inorder traversal
stays sorted, we're golden.
So those are my certificates.
There's only n of them.
So that's nice.
And we need to check that we
can compute a failure time.
This is usually really easy.
But we'll go through the
exercise of writing it down.
So I want to know, among
all times greater than
or equal to now, when will x i--
am I doing strict here?
This should probably
be greater than.
Yeah, so that's why
I have an infimum.
OK, I take the earliest
moment when x i of t
is greater than x i
of plus one, which
is the opposite of
what I want, and take
the infimum of those times.
And so that will be the
moment of transition
when they're equal.
And then-- boom-- it's
going to jump over.
I'm assuming these
things are continuous.
AUDIENCE: That's why
you take the infimum?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So it would be an infimum,
because these guys
are going to cross.
I mean, I don't care about
this kind of happening.
But if it's going to
actually go across,
then there'll be the moment of
transition where they're equal.
And that's going
to be this infimum.
OK.
How do you compute that?
Well, it depends what these
trajectory functions are like.
If it's algebraic, then this
is just a polynomial thing.
You can do it in bounded degree.
You can do it in constant time.
That's our model.
OK, so you put them
into a priority queue.
Do this advance.
And now, the question is,
how do you process an event?
When one of these
things happens,
you're about to
transition to x i
being bigger than x i plus one.
What do you do?
So that's the real heart
of the data structure.
Although, really, the heart
of a kinetic data structure
is the choice of certificates.
If you choose certificates
well, then you're
going to be efficient.
We haven't defined
efficient yet.
We will.
Otherwise, you're not
going to be so fast.
So it's all about using
certificates right.
The rest is kind
of straightforward.
So let's suppose that this
certificate is about to fail.
And we're guaranteed by this
algorithm that it fails now.
We have advanced to the time
when it is about to fail.
We process that event.
So now is the time when
these two things are equal.
Right after now, we will
get to greater than.
So here's what I do.
Swap them in the
binary search tree.
So right now, maybe
just in general,
it's going to look
something like this.
We have x i, x i plus one.
Or it could be the reverse
scenario, where x i plus one
is a leaf, and x i
is the predecessor.
Right now, they're
equal in value.
So I'm just going to interchange
them, move x i up here.
So it's a little confusing.
But this is x i plus
one, and this is x i.
Replace those.
These are really pointers
to the trajectories,
however they're described.
Interchange them.
It's still valid as
a binary search tree.
Actually, this
binary search tree
never becomes invalid, because
at this moment, they're equal.
And after now,
things will continue
to be OK, because this guy
will be bigger than this one.
That's the assumption.
We just need to fix
the certificates.
Fixing the data structure was
pretty trivial-- constant time.
So what certificates
do we need to do?
We need to add this
new certificate.
I'm going to call it
x i prime is less than
or equal to x i plus one prime.
So this is actually
x i plus one,
formerly known as x i plus
one, formerly known as x i.
But it'd be really confusing.
So I'm going to use the primes
to be the new data structure.
Because this is always the
kind of certificate we want.
We also need to
update certificates.
So there used to be an x i minus
one less than or equal to x i.
We want to turn that into
x i minus one less than
or equal to x i prime.
And we used to have an x i less
than or equal to x i plus one.
We want to turn that
into x i prime less than
or equal-- oh, that
one, we already did.
Sorry.
So I want x i plus
one to x i plus two.
And I want to do, now, x i
plus one prime to x i plus two.
OK, basically, wherever
the primes happen,
which is x i and x i plus one--
whatever certificates
they're involved in,
you have to update them--
meaning, rip out the old
one, put in the new one.
And the main issue
here is that you have
to maintain the priority queue.
So you've got to take them
out of the priority queue,
recompute their failure times,
put them back in the priority
queue with that failure time.
But the point is, this is a
constant number of updates.
In general, pretty much, as long
as the things you're messing
with-- the items
you're changing--
are involved in a small
number of certificates each,
then this will be cheap.
I'm writing this explicitly.
But in general, it's just,
update whatever certificates
those points were involved in.
The issue is how many
things you change,
and how many certificates
each of those things is in.
In this case, changing
a constant number
of things-- each of them
is in a constant number
of certificates.
So it's not constant time,
but a constant number
of calls to priority queue
updates-- so log n time.
AUDIENCE: Question.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So but how do you
find the things that you just
changed in the priority
queue of the failure times.
ERIK DEMAINE: How do you find
them in the priority queue?
How do you find these x
i's and x i plus ones?
Every point knows
what certificates
it's in, meaning it
has a point or two--
a list of certificates it's in.
There's only two of them.
And each certificate
has a pointer
into its existence in
the priority queue.
So then you know where it
is in the priority queue
and you can rip it out.
Yeah.
Lots of pointers
and cross-linking.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in something
that's pseudo algebraic,
any certificate of interest
changes o of one times.
But here, there's o of n
squared-- even though we're
only taking n
certificates at a time,
there's o of n squared possible
certificates in each of them.
ERIK DEMAINE: You're
asking about efficiency,
which we'll go to now.
This looks disconcerting,
because even though pseudo
algebraic gives us that each
certificate won't change
too many times, there
are quadratic number
of potential certificates.
They could all become relevant.
And indeed, that is the case,
if you have these points, spaced
out a lot, and then
you have these points,
spaced out a little--
four and four.
And these guys are all moving
constant velocity this way.
And the white guys
are stationary.
Then what happens?
Well, there's event, event,
event, event, event, event,
event, event, event,
event, event, event, event.
You're going to get
n squared events.
You get, like, n over two each
time you cross a white point.
I call this OK.
Why?
Because of efficiency.
The claim is, this is sort of
the best you could hope to do.
So in that sense, it's as
good as you can hope to do.
If you want to
maintain predecessors--
let's put it this way.
If we need to know--
"know" is a sort
of vague thing--
the sorted order of the points,
then you need an event--
if we're going to keep a
data structure that is always
accurate now-- so this is
sort of an assumption--
then you need an event every
time you have an order change.
That's sort of a tautology.
But it's a perspective.
And what's happening
here is that we
have an event every time
there's an order change.
So sometimes, yeah,
it's going to be bad.
Worst case here is quadratic.
You can actually prove
for pseudo algebraic,
it is order n squared events.
So this was really
a lower bound.
But it is also order n
squared all the time,
because, if you look
at any pair of guys,
they're only going to change a
constant number of times who's
above whom, for
pseudo algebraic,
if there are no change events.
So for efficiency,
because it's really hard
to analyze if points are
changing their trajectories all
the time, assume
there's no changes.
We basically just
advance to infinity.
How much could
that possibly cost?
That's how kinetic people
like to analyze things.
And for this problem, for
maintaining sorted order
at all times, the worst case
answer is theta n squared.
This data structure
achieves theta n squared,
so we consider it worst case
optimal, in this weird sense.
OK, this is if you really want
to maintain the sorted order.
Now, we didn't say we wanted
We said we want to maintain
a predecessor data structure.
But it feels kind of like those
are the same thing, maybe.
I don't know if there's a
formal sense in which this
is the case.
And efficiency, in general, is
the vaguest part of kinetic.
And for each problem,
you have to think
hard to understand,
what does efficient
mean for this problem?
But maybe don't even
worry about efficiency--
what does a lower bound mean--
but bottom line is-- worst
case, n squared events,
if there are no
change operations.
So you can think of the
running time, if you want,
of jumping to infinity as order
n squared in the worst case.
That's how we
analyze these things.
There are other things
we'd like to analyze.
Efficiency is one of them.
We have three others,
which I sort of hinted at.
There's responsiveness, which
is time spent to do an event.
So when a certificate
is invalidated,
how much time does
it take to do that?
There's locality, which
is closely related.
This is the number of--
oh, I see-- number of
certificates per data object.
I said over here, this is
good, because each item
x i is only involved
in a constant number
of certificates.
So we say the
locality is constant--
constant number of
certificates per object.
Usually, locality
implies responsive.
As long as you can update
the data structure,
you can also update the
certificates in whatever--
you pay a log factor,
because you're
updating a priority queue.
But you can update
all those events,
or redo all the
certificates in an event,
provided you are local.
So locally usually implies
responsive, more or less.
And then-- what's the
other one-- compact.
This is about space.
And we just like the number
of certificates to be small.
So in this case, number
of certificates is linear.
That's that up here.
So we consider the structure
to be optimally compact.
You need at least n.
So in our case, we're getting
order n here, order one here,
order log n here.
And efficiency I guess you'd
call constant, kind of.
Efficiency is the ratio
of how many events
you do divided by how many
events you need to do.
And here, it is optimal,
in a certain vague sense.
Sorry, that's a
little unsatisfying.
But it's unsatisfying.
That's the literature
for that problem.
We're going to do
another problem, which is
more satisfying, I would say.
And it kind of shows
you why kinetic problems
are pretty interesting.
Data structures are
often pretty darn simple,
and the fun part
is the analysis.
Or, where it can get
intricate is the analysis.
So let's solve kinetic heap.
Our goal is to be
able to do find min.
And yeah, there's also
insertions and deletions.
But I'm not going
to think about them.
Because they're not
really that different.
They're kind of like a change.
Let's not worry about it.
The goal is to
maintain the minimum.
Now, if you look at this point
set and their velocities,
how many times does
the minimum change?
Once.
Initially, the min is this.
Eventually, the
min will be this--
one change to the minimum.
So this data structure is a bad
way to maintain the minimum.
Yes, it does
maintain the minimum.
But it's going to spend a
quadratic number of events
in this situation, where
the min only changes once.
So can we get a--
ideally, you have
one certificate,
which is like, this
point is the minimum.
But that's not such
a good certificate,
because then, every
point is involved in it.
And how do you know when
it's going to be violated?
I guess you could compute it in,
like, linear time or something.
It's not a good plan.
We need to break down
the certificates that
only involve a constant
number of things
and maintain the minimum.
And somehow, I want to get below
quadratic number of events,
in the worst case.
And you can.
And you do it with a heap.
Remember heaps?
Store min heap.
So min heap has this property.
You have x, y, and z.
Then x is less
than or equal to y,
and x is less than
or equal to z.
This is nice, because--
local property.
These are my certificates.
For every node x, I have
to have this property.
So I have order n certificates.
That's good.
I had order n
certificates before.
But I claim these,
magically, are
easier to maintain than
those, even though they
look almost the same--
kind of crazy.
I don't know if I
really need to write it,
but how do we do an event?
If x and y are about
to invert in order--
so currently, x lets me go to y.
In a moment, x will
be bigger than y.
I swap x and y, update
all the certificates--
constant for each.
There's two items I'm moving.
Each one is involved in a
constant of certificates--
three now, instead of two--
but constant number of
certificate changes and stuff--
AUDIENCE: Question.
ERIK DEMAINE: --log n time.
I update the priority queue.
Question?
AUDIENCE: How is it three?
ERIK DEMAINE: Why
is it three? x is
involved in a certificate
with its two children,
and with its parent.
Its parent has a
relation, as well.
Yeah.
So you have to be careful
in counting locality.
How many certificates
in each object in?
OK so we're responsive--
log n time, local, constant,
certificates per object,
compact, linear number
certificates-- all
these are the same.
Big issue is about efficiency.
How many events is
it, in the worst case?
How many events do I need?
OK, here, for
kinetic heap, where
I want to maintain the
minimum at all times,
there's actually a
very clear lower bound.
The number of events--
or let's say, the number
of changes to the min--
I think this is what some
people call external events.
Like, you can't control
when the min changes.
The user controls that by how
they set up the trajectories.
Changes to the min is at
least n in the worst case.
It's pretty easy to set this up.
You have a point, another point
moving at constant velocity
to the left, it will overtake.
You have another point farther
away, with a bigger velocity,
to the left.
It will overtake after this
one overtakes-- and, you know,
something like this.
You've got to make
sure they don't all
cross at the same moment.
But this one will go first, and
then this guy will cross over.
And eventually--
So it's easy to set up.
The min can change a
linear number of times.
I claim in this data
structure, well, of course,
the min will change, at most,
a linear number of times.
Well, it's not
clear it's at most.
But that's true.
What we care about
though, is, we're
storing way more
certificates than the min.
We have a linear
number of certificates.
I claim the total number of
events in this data structure,
if there are no change
operations, if we just
advance to infinity--
number of events
is order n log n.
And so we call the
efficiency log n,
because you're log in factor
away from this lower bound.
This is the interesting part.
And this requires a proof.
So why is the number of
events order n log n?
We're going to prove this by
amortization, with a somewhat
tedious potential function.
But it's sort of
the obvious one.
At a time t, I wanted to find
my potential at time t to be,
how many events will
happen in the future?
This is the thing
I want to bound.
So I want to prove this is
order n log n at time zero.
But let's think about
how it changes over time.
So I'm going to rewrite
this as follows.
I'm going to Sum
over all items x.
And we're thinking about
the potential at time t.
So I look-- x is in some node.
And which node it's
in changes over time.
But at time t,
it's in some node.
I look at all the
descendants of that node.
I look at those items.
And I see which of
those items will
overtake x in a future time.
Those are the ones
that I care about.
When you overtake an ancestor,
that's when an event happens.
I claim these two
things are equal.
I probably don't even
need to prove that.
So this is in parentheses.
Don't worry about
this being equal.
Think of this as the
potential function.
Now, I want to look at an
event and see how this changes.
I need a little
bit more notation.
I'm going to call this
thing phi of t comma x.
So phi of t is the sum over
all x of this thing, which
is phi of t comma x--
number of descendants
of x at this time that
will, in the future,
overtake x, meaning their key
will get larger than x.
OK.
I can also expand phi
of t, x in a simple way.
It's kind of trivial.
But if I look at each child
of x-- there's two of them--
call that y-- and then
measure how many descendants
of y at time t will overtake x?
So it's almost the
same words, but I
changed one of the x's to
a y-- but only one of them.
Sorry-- "future" I
write greater than "t."
This is a different quantity--
slightly different--
which I'm going to call
phi of t comma x comma y.
I just need to be able
to talk about this.
So this is mostly to
introduce notation.
OK, and descendants of y--
this is including y itself.
So there's y and all of its
children-- descendants--
whatever--
which are those that
will overtake x.
If I add that up
for both children,
that is the total
number of descendants
of x that will overtake x.
So this equality is trivial.
Mainly, I wanted
to introduce that.
OK.
So what now?
Let's look at an event,
and see what changes.
So-- try a little bigger--
x, y, z.
Let's say we need to
change it to y, x, z.
Because y is about
to overtake x.
How does the potential change?
OK, well, potential is the
sum of all these phi t, x's.
So which of these
phi t, x's change?
I claim that phi of--
I'm going to call it t-plus,
which is the moment right after
now-- infintesimally larger--
I claim it does not
change for most vertices.
It only changes for x and y.
If x and y are the guys
that are switching order,
this will not change
for any others.
Why is that?
Because we're looking at number
of descendants to some vertex
that will overtake that vertex.
So do the descendants change?
No.
Descendants of x and y
change, but no one else,
their descendants change.
This is just a swap of
two adjacent elements.
Will overtaking change?
No.
I mean, overtaking
doesn't change.
If you're going to be overtaken
by x before, you still
be overtaken by x.
And it's still a
descendant-- unless it
was y. y is the only one
for which it changed.
OK, so we only have
to think about x and y
and how their
potentials are changing.
OK.
So let's look at x.
x is pretty simple.
x went down.
So we care about now
the descendants of x.
Those are what used to
be the descendants of y.
So what are the descendants
of y that will overtake x?
That is phi of t, x, y.
That's the definition here.
The descendants of y
that will overtake x-- we
had that written down.
So that is its new potential,
except as a minus 1,
because y used to
be a descendant that
would overtake x.
But it just overtook x--
not going to happen again.
Not gonna happen again.
I'm assuming here affine
motion, I suppose.
It could really happen a
constant number of times.
But let's keep it simple.
OK.
That was easy.
Next one's a little harder.
The other one is y.
What is the new potential of y?
y has new descendants now.
It used to just have
this many descendants.
It still has those descendants.
It now has x, which
doesn't matter,
if we assume it will
never be overtaken again.
And now, it has this
whole subtree of z.
So we have whatever it used
to have, which is phi of t, y.
That's all it's old descendants.
And now we have this new
thing phi of t, y, z.
If you plug that into here, that
is the number of descendants
of z that will overtake y.
That's the new thing
that we add on.
So this is an increase.
This was a decrease and
this is an increase.
We hope that they're
about the same.
In fact, they will
be basically equal.
So first claim is this is,
at most, this other thing--
phi of t, y--
phi of t, x, z.
So I'm just replacing
this y with an x.
Why is this true?
Because this is overtaking y.
If you're going to
overtake y at this time,
you would overtake
x at this time.
Because x and y are
equal right now.
I'm pretty sure this
is actually equal.
I don't know why I wrote my
notes "less than or equal to."
Less than or equal
to is all I need.
But I think, at
this moment in time,
when they're actually
equal to each other,
it doesn't matter whether
you have x and y here.
You will overtake
one if and only
if you overtake the
other at this moment.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: No, I see.
Right.
Actually, this is
about future time.
In future time, we
know that y is always
going to be less than x,
because it's moving up.
In future time,
if you overtake y,
you'll certainly
overtake x, because--
no, the other way around.
If you overtake x, meaning you
go below x, one of these ways--
overtaking is actually
going up in the tree,
but it's actually
getting smaller in value.
If you get smaller than
y, you rise above y.
That means you will have
already risen above x.
You already be a
value smaller than x.
So hopefully, that
is the way that it's
less than or equal to.
Because that's what we need.
OK, good.
Now, I understand.
AUDIENCE: So at this point,
we're assuming affine?
ERIK DEMAINE: We're
assuming affine.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Forgot to mention that.
I think this works
for pseudo algebraic,
but this proof does not,
assuming that x and y only
switch places once.
OK, then we have this simple
equation, which is phi of t,
x equals phi of t, x,
y plus phi of t, x, z,
where you just sum
over the two children.
So this is phi of t, x, z.
So-- I need more space, I guess.
So phi of t, x, z, that is phi
of t, x minus phi of t, x, y.
So we have, let's say,
on the left-hand side,
is less than or equal
to phi of t, y plus--
this is what we had
before-- t of x, z.
But now, that is the same as phi
of t, x minus the other child.
Sorry-- y.
OK, that was just that equation.
Now, do things simplify?
Hope so.
Phi of t, y--
these two things--
OK.
Not so pretty.
What we care about is
the sum of these things.
We care about sum--
the overall potential.
So we want phi of t-plus
is phi of t plus something.
How it changes is, well, how
does phi of t prime x change?
Well, it went down a lot.
It went all the way
down to phi of t, x, y.
Well, actually, we just
add these together.
Add them up.
This is messy.
Sorry.
Let's look at this sum--
phi of t plus x and y.
So we get this thing--
phi of t, x, y minus 1.
And then we get this thing-- so
phi of t, y, plus phi of t, x,
minus phi of t, x, y.
It's an elaborate way of
saying this cancels with this.
So we are left with
the old value--
phi of t, x, plus
phi of t, y, minus 1.
So that means phi--
sorry, this is less
than or equal to.
This means phi of t-plus is less
than or equal phi of t minus 1.
In other words, every
time an event happens,
the potential goes
down by at least one.
This is basically confirming
this intuition, but roughly.
But our definition
was this-- the number
of descendants of x that
overtake x in the future.
How big could this thing be?
It is, at most, the sum
over all nodes of the number
of descendants of that node.
So it is, by definition,
at most, n log n.
If we look at phi of
0, it's order n log n.
And what we're doing is
using a balanced heap here.
And so for order n
log n, initially,
in every event that
happens, we go down by one.
And we're never negative.
That thing is
always non-negative.
Then the number of events
is, at most, order n log n.
Cool?
OK, I only have one
more page of notes
to cover in zero minutes--
about 15 seconds.
Let me quickly tell you
about what's on this page,
and you can read it at home.
It's a little survey of lots
of different kinetic data
structures, in particular,
for more than one dimension.
So there's a lot of
work on 2D convex hull.
You have moving points
in two dimensions.
You want to maintain
the convex hull.
The number of events--
the best we know how
to achieve is order n
to the two plus epsilon--
a little bit bigger
than n squared.
And there's a lower bound that
it can change n squared times.
So it's almost optimal--
unknown how to do that in 3D.
A problem that we solved in
the open problems in this class
two years ago is
smallest enclosing disk.
So you have points
moving in the plane,
and you want to maintain,
what is the smallest
enclosing disk of those points?
Number of events we got was
n to the 3 plus epsilon,
which is a little bit painful.
Best lower round is n squared--
so still a gap there.
Those closely related to
another open problem, which
is, you want to
maintain something
called a Delaunay triangulation.
If you know what that is, great.
If not, it's a
big open problem--
how many times can the
Delaunay triangulation
change if you have just points
moving along straight lines?
Best upper bound is n cubed.
Best lower bound is n squared--
so similar linear gap.
If you just want to
maintain some triangulation
on your points,
you can do better.
Best upper bound is
n to the 2.33333.
Best lower bound is n squared.
So a smaller gap--
just cube root of n gap.
Collision detection is probably
the most obvious application
here.
You have a video game.
Things are moving
with known velocities.
You update those
velocities-- like,
you have bullets, and
people running around,
and whatever you
want to know when
they bounce into each other--
walls, which are stationary.
When does that happen?
There's pretty good algorithms
for kinetic collision
detection.
Although, it's very unclear
what efficient means.
Because you want to
optimize for the case
when not many collisions happen.
And these algorithms do-- in a
certain sense, they're optimal.
But it's much harder to
state what that sense is.
Minimum spanning tree
is another one I have.
This is tough.
Easy thing to do is, you
do kinetic predecessor
on the entire sorted
order of the edge lengths.
And then you just run
a [? stem ?] thing that
processes the edges in order.
So that gets a quadratic
number of events.
It's unknown whether you can do
any better for minimum spanning
tree.
So that was your quick
survey of kinetic.
And that ends geometry.
The end.